you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and just got paired up with mr. Aman
Hamilton I am gosu okay
let's try an M so Indian yeah and let's
try a dark square strategy d6 and e5 go
with the classical Queen c2 mm-hmm
I think we could go straight in for e5
yeah let's play e5 right now if push I
have to take first otherwise night here
Queen a4 hits with the fork hmm might be
a to d7 I think so
hmm heading for c5 you know let's do
that they could get this move in because
they have pressure on e5 they only need
one piece on it so his delay with this
next move tells me that my move was it
may be a bit off okay Bishop g4 and then
Knight here maybe no let's go straight
in
for this looking for a five just to kind
of halt the queenside expansion the pawn
break I'll be looking to get in is a
five so let's see let's start with this
now it'll take a little bit more time I
thought maybe before instead of Bishop
to e2 okay so they're gonna have to go
about it that way so actually suppose I
do this you know let's do that right now
actually 90 d2 incoming
and maybe mm-hmm let me do this move
provoke f3 and then drop back and then
maybe I could look for Knight age 5 into
f4 so let's go here
keep them developed and hmm let's go in
for this Knight f4 if g3 maybe Bishop h3
this should be a little bit inconvenient
by inducing this it enables Knight h5
I'm considering on b4 maybe night to a6
also I'm in the position to play of 5
maybe Queen here they don't have the
dark square Bishop on this natural
diagonal mm-hmm I feel pretty good about
my position f5 sitting pretty quick
connected with this night on c5 which is
only temporary granted he will be kicked
in short order with b3
I'm not sure what candidate moves there
are even on before I can consider a
night here right away
Brooke here's maybe something they're
considering Brooke f2 it seems a little
awkward
okay night here or f4 I kind of like f4
first Queen g5 is another idea
f5 b4
actually I'm not fearing F before I'm
gonna keep some flexibility with my
night I don't want to run in here all
right away on b4 I have night here and I
get the dark square bishop probably
should have noticed that sooner hmm I'm
even considering something like f4
Knight g3 okay do I not get that dark
square bishop okay let's try this also
their diagonal is open so maybe stuff
like this is an idea I could go ahead
and grab the pond I think they should or
maybe c5 actually c5 is maybe strong on
c5 I can consider Queen here first
threatening to pick up the fish up but I
think Bishop here covers everything this
has to be a little bit awkward having
the rook come off the F file cuz I could
take and have the F file up and up mmm
suppose I just play this move I'm gonna
do that and I shouldn't take him right
away
um be happy to see that actually alright
let's play it and be active with my
queen
can't be bad right where else is she
gonna go they're gonna get in c5 but
I'll play on the a file on push I'll be
sure to take here and then take on b4
this is a future target on d6 I'm
actually head on the clock I wouldn't
have expected that okay
increasing the pressure here hmm maybe
and then here right now now let's get
the a file first take let's take here
first I feel like I should have
something here definitely
hmm what about rook a3 there's
definitely a tactic here let's start
with this their nights out of play their
bishops passive looks passive okay clean
their that's a concession okay
put pressure on that pawn okay three
night here should be strong now maybe I
should have done wreck a3 a little
sooner okay let's do this they're
Knights pinned Bishop a4 double up on
the a file night here okay let's do this
pressure here hmm
let's keep their books active let's
trade 1 & 2 enter with the bishop
in the night and then play here next hmm
I think I'm winning now rook takes
Knight okay
is there something quicker let's take
care and get my bishop before he's
trapped
let's take push let's go here hmm I get
some material here my bishops in an
ideal spot it should be a win it's got
to go fast okay just now stalemates and
then we should have it move it's not
expecting that that uh to be a head on
the clock like that hmm okay let me go
back into it the analysis I think I
missed some tactic let me see do I have
this on okay yeah I feel like I missed
some tactic and maybe hang on before I
even go over it with the computer arrows
me
hmm yeah I think right around this point
here after I played a night to be 8 I
think that that was off no maybe not so
much I think this is the right idea but
I wonder my point here is that I'm
wondering some about maybe oh ok yeah
the analysis just came up I'm wondering
some about c5 because in the game I mean
a lot of time is invested in playing c5
and I think that it could hit just right
now well I guess no matter where I go
with the night this is a possibility and
you know just trying to break down the
dark squares bring him to life so and
this is one other point maybe instead of
Bishop to e2 I wonder about v4 sometimes
the drawback with v4 is you know you
could play a 5 but when b4 is played
here the bishop defends the rope so yeah
not sure Knight B to d7
I think B 4 because if B 4 is in played
now then this B 4 idea has to come at a
snail's pace with B 3 a 3 and then B 4
and that's a lot of Tempe so hmm I think
maybe in the end white can save a move
if they're applying b4 at this moment
instead of Bishop to e2 and I don't
think that this is something I could
take advantage of you know you know
these two moves the difference between
the two I think Y could very easily do
this
there should be two a5 yeah and this is
the point I mean if you're going with a
three they're never getting in c5
because I could play four nights e5 and
there's no B far and there's no B 4
because I could take
so hmm okay once we got to this point I
felt pretty comfortable and I think that
this is an important move Bishop g4
inducing f3 and this this permits Knight
h5 which is desirable because there's
only one active plan I have in this
position and that's the f5 break so I
just retreat and stay developed and then
start focusing on these dark squares
Queen g5 Knight f4 these are very active
posts so this is quite natural and I
mean it seemed perfectly sensible to me
this is a popular reorganisation of the
pieces to have the rook here and the
bishop basically negate the night for
when he arrives on f4 it may even be the
case that the king will have to spend
white will have to spend an additional
move to play King h1 the Knights on f4
and the Queen's here Knights I know 4
and the Queen's on g5 there's a knight
h3 threatened there was even one point
in the game where there was the
possibility for perpetual well a
perpetual idea I believe is present with
the knight enough for and the Queen on g
g5 with knight check king h1 in the
knight f2 just bouncing back and forth
and these two squares so yeah I'm
feeling really comfortable here because
I have the f5 break in and yeah I didn't
notice this until a little while it took
some time for me to realize that I had
this idea which is quite useful to keep
in mind with connected with the bishop
on d7 normally this night will have to
run in Reverse but hmm not the case here
he could actually move forward and I
hunt down that dark square bishop which
is there better at the two bishops yeah
and I wonder maybe at this moment
they've played before I play tonight
there maybe this is the moment where
they should take and then well I don't
know I think I would play this because
I'm threatening this for the moment
bishop there and here's here's the
example I was pointing out earlier
tonight a knight on f4 this is a threat
to at least draw something like this but
uh and I know I'm not sure what the
computer will be suggesting around here
let me see what the graph is saying okay
I don't know if this is like a khalad
Vantage for white due to the space
advantage sure okay to see one it's kind
of tough because I have really active
pieces right about here let me put on
the engine right around here if we do
piece comparison let me put the arrows
up for - oh I missed that they had that
both I think we both missed that after
rook a to c1 they're threatening to tuck
the bishop away play Queen here and then
they played in the night there we both
missed this idea they can maintain that
dark square bishop hmm and then maybe do
this and then c5 and it's a much
different game because one way to look
at this this night on a5 if he's not
kept making that capture of the bishop
and this rook is kind of he's not going
to come to life you know he's gonna have
to move before the rook has any activity
on the white side of the
so v6 okay c1 yeah
and it's right around here where when
you do a piece comparison all these
pieces are really good that I have both
rooks on completely open files compared
to these guys
strong queen pose to Bishop and this
isn't hitting fast enough so right
around here I was saying that I thought
I had some tactic but I guess not it's
saying just a pawn advantage with Knight
to f6 mm-hmm no it seems more active
okay Knight f4 yeah it's it's tough to
defend though I mean what other than
okay suppose King H ones to the Queen g3
because that's clearly a concession and
doubled pawns but it's more than that
it's giving up the g4 square mm-hmm so
suppose King h1 here okay - Roxy to take
stakes and then here you know he's just
a - stronger piece this isn't a winning
advantage but it's certainly comfortable
hmm okay I have this play out so quite
happy with how the endgame played out
here is getting my pieces active and
that c5 move just never came so what
that basically means is I didn't have to
babysit any pond because given time you
know if I'm making nothing moves see
five hits takes takes let's just do
another nothing move takes takes in the
end there's finally some target for
white to bite at and you could very
easily see this Knight sweeping in to c4
and then what happens it's me who's on
the defensive if black is quick to apply
pressure here and if I'm having it
having to defend these pieces then
or if I'm having to defend my pawn my
pieces can't really be pieces and do
some aggressive things no so let me go
back to the just for a moment in the
middle game see if there were some
adjustments here okay it's suggesting 97
but this is this has to be a line as
well oh and this is the move I wanted to
look at back to basics huh
you can't play c5 right away because the
Knight takes d5 okay so after E for
night here okay
all right okay well now it is pointing
out b4 so yeah so I guess that's a I
don't know how big of an improvement but
I believe it saves one tempo maybe more
no playing b4 right away because in the
game what did he do he went beats beat
the the pawns journey was B 3 and then B
4 so I guess you could get this in and
should get it in it's even suggesting
this but now 83 to most to acquire this
instead of 3 I don't know just a small
little timing detail and yeah thanks
Bishop g4 push it back okay with f5 yeah
I don't know tough game a tight game
it's a good player ok
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye